there was one study they showed a series
of women videos of men and then at the
end they asked these women how sexually
attractive is this man then they showed
a group of men the same videos of these
same guys and asked them How likely is
it that this man would win a physical
fight with another man then the
researchers attract those men in those
videos and had them return 18 months
later and ask them a bunch of questions
including how many sexual partners have
you had over the last 18 months the
correlation between how sexually
attractive the women found these men and
how many partners they had was Zero but
there was a strong and significant
correlation between how intimidating or
formidable men rated them and how many
sexual partners they recounted over the
last 18 months and so essentially how
tough a guy looks to men is a stronger
predictor of his sexual success than how
attractive he looks to women
you just defended your PhD thesis what's
that mean
that's right so PhD thesis it's called a
dissertation in the U.S they call it a
thesis here in the UK it's just a it's a
culmination of the work you do
throughout your years of study in a
doctoral program so at least within the
field of psychology typically you write
uh you know a handful of papers maybe
three or four papers and it's all
supposed to build toward some
overarching uh hypothesis some kind of
framework and you run a series of
empirical studies and you know hopefully
you get the results you're looking for
and then that sort of you know it sort
of builds towards you know here's here's
what all of this means here's how it
contributes to the research to the
literature more broadly and uh it's
supposed to be the sort of original
piece of scholarship it doesn't
necessarily have to be empirical either
sometimes it can be theoretical and I'm
sure there's like a whole other set of
uh criteria for the Humanities but yeah
it's a it's a huge relief I mean people
say oh when you're finished your PhD
these are going to be so happy you're
going to be so thrilled that I was just
like relieved you know afterwards I was
just like oh thank God is over like it's
done it's you know even though it went
well you know I got the outcome I wanted
uh it was still just um you know it was
still more just like this burden is
lifted rather than just feeling elated
or something you know what's the thesis
so the title of my PhD thesis is
physical and social threats fortify
moral judgments and I got really
interested in this uh when I was in
undergrad so I was taking uh classes by
this experimental philosopher Josh Nob
who uh that's where basically I learned
that you can use the tools of empirical
psychology and social science to test
people's moral intuitions and morality
generally has been kind of the
Wheelhouse of philosophy you know
armchair philosophers you know pondering
what is morality you know what does it
mean to be a moral person what is moral
character and with you know some some of
the uh the instruments in Psychology you
can come along and say like well what do
people actually think about morality
what does the average person think about
it and you know maybe some of your
listeners will know about you know like
administering the the trolley problem to
people would people flip the switch
would they not that kind of thing and I
was taking classes with with Paul Bloom
too uh when I was in undergrad and
learned about the sort of Developmental
origins of morality and while I was
there I learned about this intro
interesting link between disgust and
morality and many people think of
disgust as this emotion that people
experience in response to uh you know
contamination illness infection but
there's a lot of interesting work
indicating that it overlaps with our
moral uh judgments as well that people
who are very sensitive to disgust also
tend to condemn wrongdoers more harshly
if you induce disgust in people show
them some disgusting images or get them
to smell some repulsive odors
subsequently their moral judgments
become intensified and so I would I
thought to myself you know when I was
reading all of this and when I came to
Cambridge I was wondering is there you
know are there other forms of threat
Beyond contamination you know
contamination is a threat to your
survival it's an evolutionary threat are
there other kinds of evolutionary
threats challenges to your survival and
potentially your reproduction
um that could also intensify your moral
judgment so I did some stuff on you know
people who were worried about covid in
2020 were also uh stricter in their
moral judgments for a variety of
different kinds of moral violations not
just things like you know some of the
items I used were you know using a
stranger's toothbrush how wrong do you
think that is and of course like of
course people who are worried about
covet will also say like using a
toothbrush that doesn't belong to you is
you know that's that's horrible but it
was also things like you know betraying
a family member or stealing from a store
you know kind of deception betrayal
subversion things that are unrelated to
contamination people who are worried
about covid were uh stricter with those
kinds of violations similar to social
threat as well similar to Age the age
one was the most interesting to me
um I'm working on on this paper trying
to get it published I think you and I
might have talked about this offline
before too uh that essentially uh
there's an there's a direct association
between as people grow older their moral
judgments become stricter and this is
controlling for uh political orientation
it's controlling for income for
Education you know so these kind of
demographic variables that you would
assume you know oh when older people you
know as they as they age they they
become more politically conservative and
that's why they adopt these sort of
moralistic attitudes but even when you
control for that uh there's something
going on here about the aging process
and I suggest it has something to do
with vulnerability risk perception as
you grow older
um the threats around you appear to be
especially formidable and I suggest this
is also potentially why
um there are these interesting moral
judgment differences between men and
women such that women are more uh strict
in their moral judgments relative to men
and some of that can be explained with
um just the reproductive differences
between men and women women have
historically been more at you know more
at risk for when they're pregnant when
they're carrying young children they
should just be extra alert to potential
dangers but I also suggest that if you
control for certain things like
muscularity uh height BMI all these
other kinds of things I would bet that
the moral judgment differences and
discuss sensitivity would actually
shrink I just think that if you're a
sort of a a strong young robust and
healthy person the world just looks less
dangerous to you and and this includes
moral wrongdoers you think like ah that
guy's doing something bad but I can I
can take him this is sort of the the the
punch line of what my thesis is about
very interesting so
I think we spoke about this last week
that
a lot of evolutionary researchers think
that morality is basically just
rule adaptive rules for human survival
uh given more fluffy and philosophical
language
oh interesting uh I mean I wouldn't call
them even even roles really I mean these
are at least you know the best versions
of I think evolutionary psychology and
social sciences supposed to be
descriptive right it sort of here's how
things are evolutionary psychology it's
about here's how things were in The
ancestral environment a lot of people
get those confused right where they
think um oh we evolved to to do X
because that's
um you know evolutionarily advantageous
but it's actually evolutionary
advantageous in the uh ancestral
environment right we're we're what is it
we're Stone Age beings and in the sort
of space age or something along you know
we're in the modern environment we
didn't evolve to live in a world with
you know Limitless calories endless
entertainment you know drugs that can
stimulate the dopaminergic system in
your brain like all of this stuff right
but a hundred thousand years ago you
know there are certain mental
adaptations that helped us survive in
that kind of environment and so they're
not really rules necessarily and in fact
you know there's a lot of the the the
psychological mechanisms that we have
they actually sort of evolve to to
counteract other people's psychological
mechanisms as well
you know like there was uh there's
debate right now I think about you know
age differences in
um in relationships for example where
women might shame men for being
interested in younger women and some men
will uh you know they'll say something
like well we we evolved to be attracted
to young women and that's true men did
evolve to be attracted to young women
because you know in The evolutionary
environment younger women were more
fertile and so on
however women evolved to use and what
people in general but in this context
women evolved to use moral Norms to
shame men so that they in turn can uh be
exploit an advantage there as well right
such that they can
um sort of Shame High status men into
not dating younger women and date them
instead and that in itself is an
evolutionary mechanism so you have all
of these sort of competing modules and
mechanisms and processes and each person
is trying to uh obtain an advantage sort
of at the level of the genes right and
so you know we could we can lob
evolutionary mechanisms at each other
well I evolved to do this you evolve to
do that and you know what I mean so so I
think that that's also important to keep
in mind when people sort of use
evolutionary explanations as an excuse
for this or that behavior it's you know
people are going to use their own sort
of evolutionary prerogative to undercut
that as well you know what I mean yeah I
mean intersexual competition has been
one of the most fascinating things I've
learned about this year uh I had
Christina Durante on talking about it
and then I've got
uh uh Joyce beninson uh toward the end
of this year oh she's great yeah who's
just going to be such money she's one I
think maybe the last episode of this
year and I can't I can't wait to have
her on but you will you sent me an
article that you've got that's just come
out called the male warrior hypothesis
what's that yeah yeah the male warrior
hypothesis uh it's funny so Joyce
Bennington has written about this uh as
have others and it's a hypothesis within
the evolutionary psychology research uh
basically suggesting that men and women
evolved different psychological
mechanisms to deal with within group in
between group conflict and so you know
based on a series of different studies
uh as well as sort of combing through
the anthropological and archaeological
record researchers have suggested that
essentially men are uh more hostile
within their groups to one another uh
especially overt hostility you know so
there's research indicating you know
early on it was it was considered
basically undisputable that men were
more aggressive to one another
um but then when researchers sort of
expanded this definition of aggression
they actually found no differences no
significant differences once they
accounted for indirect aggression things
like rumor spreading ostracism them
either ending a friendship or
threatening to end it those are sort of
these indirect aggressive Acts
and so in those cases
um there's no difference but the overt
hostility that men show one another is
is definitely more pronounced relative
to women however researchers have also
found that
um that men are more likely to suppress
their hostility toward one another when
they encounter another group of men say
a group of Outsiders and they
hypothesize that this is because in the
evolutionary environment when men are
especially young men most of this is
going to be in the context of young men
when they're within a group say an
evolutionary band 50 or 100 000 years
ago uh it's in their interest to sort of
one-up one another mock one another
tease one another and look good in that
Community especially because they're
trying to impress uh young women uh but
then also evolved to band together and
to either defend to their Community from
uh hostile Outsiders and Invaders and
they evolve to be those hostile uh
Invaders and go uh uh capture resources
and women and territory from other
groups as well and so essentially men
are are simultaneously more hostile and
more Cooperative whereas women uh their
their aggression is expressed indirectly
and verbally and sort of in this
roundabout way
And yet when they compete with other
women it's uh it appears that they're
less likely to suppress that uh that
that hostility that they show one
another and there was a there was a
study that came out uh this year Joyce
bennison was was an author of this paper
and they were looking at uh high school
and college athletes and they basically
found that uh you know they asked these
athletes questions about how they
interacted with one another when they're
on the team and how they interacted when
they were competing against other teams
and they found that generally speaking
especially for acts of overt aggression
male athletes reported more from their
own teammates you know name calling fist
fights shoving each other like I think
one of them was like spitting on me uh
you know getting shoved in a locker like
all of the kinds of stuff that that
happens uh in male sports teams right
and you know men reported more of that
happening between one another
uh but then when they when they asked
the the male athletes about how they
competed with one another against
another sports team and how much
hostility they showed their own
teammates it was it was very low uh and
essentially seemed like the the
hostility they they typically directed
toward one another suddenly became hyper
focused on defeating the other team
whereas for the female athletes uh they
reported uh you know a relatively high
amount of indirect aggression rumors
ostracism one of the items was uh you
know have you what have you ever been
left out when the other teammates went
out went to dinner without you things
like that going out to eat without you
um and there were relatively high levels
of that and then they asked these these
female athletes uh about their
experiences playing with their teammates
against another team and and again like
the the rates of of intra groups So
within group hostility we're actually
still relatively High uh you know women
relative to men were less likely to pass
the ball to one another or shun one
another or like you know maybe whisper
something to another girl uh things like
that and so
um so the overall idea of this male
warrior hypothesis is that yeah guys uh
are are sort of extra hostile uh in in
basically every single context but in a
sense they're actually more Cooperative
as well in that you know when they're up
against another group another team
perhaps another army or an invading
force uh they can sort of let those
tensions go and you know come together
with one another
and you know I think this this
distinction between indirect versus
direct aggression is important and it's
interesting because you know so so I I'm
in that piece that I I sent to you about
the male warrior hypothesis I
um discussed this excerpt from this book
uh called yanowama and it was
recommended on Twitter by by the great
David bus who I know you've had on this
show and this is an amazing book this uh
so it's the Spanish girl this European
girl in the 1930s gets kidnapped by
these uh these Amazonian in the book you
know the book was came out in the 1960s
so they refer to them as Amazonian
Indians
um and she's kidnapped as a young girl
and one of the one of the stories she
tells in her recounting of what happened
to her throughout this experience
um and she lived with them for decades
uh through with various bands of of
yanowama uh tribes yanoama is the sort
of overarching name for a whole series
of foraging communities uh in in South
America and they're constantly at war
with one another and conflict I mean
they're sort of like modern day
hunter-gatherers essentially and so
Helen Valero says that when she arrived
in this new tribe there was a a girl
there who didn't like her you know a
girl who was roughly the same age as her
and gave her this packet of folded
leaves and said like here here's a snack
for you you must be hungry and Helen
takes this snack and she smells it and
she's repulsed by the the odor and so
she sets it down somewhere and then uh a
few hours later a little boy in the in
the tribe Falls deathly ill and he says
he got this uh this little leaf packet
from from Helen below who you say you
know she gave it to me and the whole
entire tribe turns on her and they're
like why did you try to poison this boy
like who is this Outsider Girl who's
Trying to poison us like why are you
doing this to the children and they
ostracize her and banish her and she she
like literally is running through the
forest while several of the men are
shooting arrows at her trying to kill
her and they're yeah so so so this was
an interesting example of of kind of
this indirect aggression right I mean
it's not like this girl like you know
went up to her and bashed her head with
a rock or something she gave her a snack
knowing that two things could happen
right because by the way when she gave
her the snack she said if you don't like
it because she saw Helen smell it and
say I don't I don't like the smell and
she said well if you don't like you can
give it to someone else so you do two
things could happen either hell at least
listen dies or she gives it to someone
and is responsible for the death of
someone else and gets ostracized so
that's a win-win situation and this is
an act of indirect aggression but if
Helen were to die in this situation you
know this this girl Helen Bolero um
the girl who gave her the snack would
not be counted as her murderer right
like the the sort of steps between the
snack and the death of Helen Valero are
the other steps involved such that the
girl would not be blamed for this and I
think this is a sort of a an extra
interesting example of of indirect
aggression that is you know often more
perpetrated by women relative to men and
you know I I write it there that you
know if if this had been a situation
among men where like this new Outsider
male comes in and the other guys don't
like him they're not like hmm how can I
like you know kill this guy directly it
would be like you know like basically
stepping up on him and be like Show Me
What You're Made Of and just like shove
him or they'd they'd organize a way to
kill him in his sleep you know it would
be a for a very sort of direct and
forceful attempt to put this this uh
newcomer in their place and so this to
me sort of gets at this this difference
between
um you know the sort of overt male
aggression versus covert female
aggression why do you think it is that
women don't seem to band together
against uh an out-group foe in the same
way that men do
it's an interesting question
one
one possibility and perhaps the the most
you know the more the more sort of
uh convincing possibility to me is you
know sort of riffing on this this quote
from The evolutionary psychologist uh
John Toby uh he was a sort of a pioneer
of the field and he had this line it was
something like you know cultural very
like I'll believe that cultural
variation is responsible for uh uh you
know the like human nature if you show
me an example of a tribe in which women
band together to capture men as husbands
and you know there's there's literally
no example in the human record of women
ever doing that and there's a there's
another story from the uh the
Anthropologist uh Napoleon I don't know
if I'm getting his name his last name is
like shagnon
c-h-a-g-n-o-n and he talks about how so
he he would spend time he actually spent
time with with yanowama uh in South
America and
his belief as was the belief of many
other anthropologists at the time is
that you know the the reason why men in
these small-scale tribal societies go to
Wars over resources it's and especially
over meat you know capturing territory
finding Good Grounds for hunting and
those kinds of things and he uh you know
he floated this idea to these uh to to
these uh yanowama tribes and they
laughed at him and they're like that's
not where we go to war now we go to war
for women like that's the reason we like
like we like me but we like women a lot
more was actually a direct line that he
put in his book
um and so that is probably the reason
right I mean throughout this book uh
that David bus recommended on you know
they're just countless cases of men like
you know getting into conflict both
within the groups uh to to say like you
know who's going to marry this young
woman or you know who's who's uh you
know who's going to come together to to
take to take out the other the other uh
tribes around them and there's just
constant male on male violence and
conflict and it's almost inevitably uh
subtle uh surrounds this idea of um you
know who is going to marry who or who's
going to have children with who or who's
going to have more you know more sexual
partners and men have a stronger sex
drive they have more interest in variety
they have a sort of a
a reputational concern to demonstrate
how tough they are uh whereas women
don't necessarily have those same set of
concerns and also because you know women
are the more valuable sex biologically
so they don't want to get involved in
physical conflict right okay yeah it is
interesting to me that the tribalism
that we see amongst everybody smeared
across Society seems to fall apart at
least a little bit when men aren't in
the picture uh and it's like you're
talking about basically women banding
together against an out group less than
men would on average right
yeah especially the sort of overt
hostility right so so a lot of the
research supporting the male warrior
hypothesis you know it indicates that
that men show you know higher levels of
of uh preference for the end group more
like xenophobia and more sort of uh
denigration of of you know generally the
the out group whereas for women it's
it's less overtly expressed right it's
more sort of fear and avoidance you know
like if there's this sort of strange
Force just avoid it stay away from it
and and don't cause any trouble
um yeah so so that is you know there's
this sex difference there the
interesting thing I suppose is that it
suggests that human cooperation is a
consequence of human competition like
the one of the main reasons that
cooperation exists is simply because
human competition was so high
yeah yeah there's there's some
interesting uh research on the you know
they've done some sort of mathematical
modeling where they pit
um you know these these sort of
computerized simulations of well you
know what if what if one group
cooperates all the time versus some of
the time and you know what if one group
always competes and so on but basically
they find that these two things tend to
arise simultaneously that you can't
really get the kinds of high levels of
cooperation that you see with humans
without high levels of competition as
well I mean humans are like by far the
most Cooperative species on the planet I
mean we like literally can coordinate
millions or even billions of people
across the globe whereas
um we're also the most sort of deadly
species as well where we'll get into
sort of mass scale killings and conflict
and genocide and all those things but in
order to pull off a genocide you
actually have to be an extremely
Cooperative species is the kind of irony
of that right Richard ringham has
written about this and others is like
you know that sort of uh there's that
double-sided aspect of our nature is
that cooperation can lead to sort of
incredible levels of mass conflict and
and competition uh yeah because the
cooperation enables you to be able to
deploy that competition at scale and
leverage it in increasingly vicious ways
didn't I seem to remember you wrote
about
people presume that humans have got more
aggression than other animals and that
were totally undomesticated and that the
wild is perfect without us but chimps
show a 100 to 150 times the amount of
aggression than humans do and the peace
loving bonobos show less aggression than
the chimps but still way more than any
human society ever recorded
yeah yeah I wrote about that when I was
discussing uh Richard rangham's book
he's the the Harvard evolutionary
biologist he wrote a great book called
the goodness Paradox and yeah some of
the findings that he uh unearths and
discusses in that book one of them was
this yeah there's this General belief
like you know if if someone is behaving
um you know especially violently like a
serial killer or something we're like oh
he's he's inhuman you know there's
something wrong with him like where's
his Humanity uh and yet Richard rangham
points out that like actually you know
the ability to kill like at scale large
numbers of people that is uniquely a
human ability right like there's no
chimpanzee who's committed like Mass
scale genocide against their own species
the way that humans have and yeah I mean
the the Figures were stunning so so it
was um it was 150 to 500 times uh so
chimpanzees specifically within their
own groups right like this he's not even
talking about Intergroup conflict
amongst Japan he's just among their
fellow group members their peers they're
150 to 500 times more violent than uh
human hunter-gatherer uh coalitions
um and and bonobos are roughly half that
violent so you know what is that
something like 250 times uh more violent
than human beings but yes they're
they're uh their path is violent as
chimps but still far far more more
violent than human beings are and so
yeah there's uh the whole
self-domestication idea was was
fascinating to me this idea that you
know and you actually see a small scale
version of this among chimps but human
beings even more so where
part of the reason why humans are
relatively docile and cooperative and
can follow norms and all these kinds of
things and build societies is because we
care deeply about what other people
think about us we sort of have this
built-in social anxiety you know some
some researchers have called it the
sociometer uh where we sort of monitor
how we appear in the eyes of others and
the reason why we have all this is
because in the ancestral environment
this is actually before the ancestral
environment so Richard rangham suggests
this was maybe five or six hundred
thousand years ago this started
occurring what he calls the execution
hypothesis which is that whenever an
especially aggressive or hostile male
appeared within a community uh and
started monopolizing resources or taking
the other men's wives and so on it was
around this time that that humans
started to form the ability to speak so
language evolved the ability to use
tools and weapons had evolved and
the sort of uh weaker and less
formidable men were able to form the
sort of whispering consensus of like hey
this guy's a problem like he you know he
took my wife he took your wife like you
know what's going so how do we get rid
of this guy and so they wait for him to
fall asleep or they'd um there's one
example that he points out in the book
of uh of this hunter-gatherer group
there was a there was this sort of
bullying mail that the others didn't
like
and so I think they they dared him to
climb up this tree to get some some you
know particularly appealing fruit and so
the guy sets his weapons down he's like
you know I'll show you guys let me get
this piece of fruit up at this tree and
he climbs up the tree and when he comes
down the guys just you know they take
his weapons that he had left and just
start stabbing him and you know problem
solved and so so the the guys who cared
uh who who had no
um or or little to no uh
um sort of concern about their
reputation or how they appeared of like
I'm just gonna do what I want to just be
this sort of bad boy alpha male
um if they weren't able to to cultivate
allies and to uh sort of develop a
reputation as a useful person in that
group then the others would just kill
them right and so we are the descendants
of the humans who didn't die and who did
sort of develop over time is concern
about like you know any any kind of
ridicule criticism any sort of stinging
comment uh that that lingers with us
because you know in the ancestral
environment you know every single
negative comment could have potentially
life-threatening consequences
life is too difficult ancestrally for
people to get through on their own which
means that inevitably you need
cooperation that means that you need to
temper down the aggression the dark
Triad traits that you've got all of that
stuff you need to bring that down to a
level which is uh perhaps sufficiently
high that it means you are more
effective than your competitors but not
so high that it crosses the threshold
where you get your weapons taken away
from you while you're up a tree and get
stabbed on the way down that's the
balance yeah that's that's people are
trying that's a neat kind of uh yeah
that's that's like it's a sort of a it's
a neat way to tie that in what you're
saying with you with the male warrior
hypothesis where you need a little bit
of that sort of aggression and that
callousness uh because you know if you
had none of that then you would just be
overrun by a more aggressive Community
uh but if you had too much of it then
the whole Community would start to fall
apart and people would be hostile and
suspicious to one another yes also I
suppose the males ancestral that would
have been a little bit more aggressive
would have been seen as more useful you
know they would have been formidable uh
foes and useful allies for people to
have and again it's pushing that too far
it's it's that I I've really really
enjoyed some of the conversations I've
had about Psychopaths recently and uh
Kevin Dutton he's the uh head of the
communication of science for Auckland
University in in Australia or Adelaide
Maybe
and he was talking about this saying
it's adaptive to have a couple of
psychopaths in your group because it
means that if you've got to go and do
some really messed up stuff you can just
send them in there they're the Special
Forces they're the Berserkers they're
the Vikings going to raid lindisfarne or
whatever and it's useful to have them
but as soon as you start to get too many
it makes for a very unstable Society so
you can't hold on to that speaking about
some of the uh secondary sex
characteristics and the male competition
stuff I had this idea about Dad bods
after I saw a competition online so
there's a video I saw a video go up
about Dad bods and I noticed in the
comments a lot of mail accounts really
really upset they seem to be very
triggered very uh discounting it was a
woman that was talking about why she
likes dad Bots and my dad bods are
superior to guys that think that they're
in shape and a lot of guys in the
comments telling this woman that she
doesn't know what she's talking about
which you know it's just it is the
internet for you and you don't know I
don't know how much this one was
posturing how much she was doing as a
massive troll whatever and it got me
thinking about why it is that guys seem
to have such an aversion to women
specifically praising and the press and
the media sort of upholding dad bods as
some sort of
um a pedestal that men should try and
attain and I think that there's a lot of
things going on here the first most
obvious one is that guys that train
don't want their efforts that they've
put into their own physique to be in
vain right that makes that makes a lot
of sense they have decided that this is
something which is worthy of getting
there is almost no guy on the planet who
would be able to say with a straight
face that they're going to the gym and
training hard without it including in
that I'm doing this to make myself more
attractive to women uh or whoever it is
that they're trying to be attractive to
so that's that's the first one but I
don't think that that really accounts
for anywhere near the kind of effect
that we're seeing here I think another
element is that most men
even if they're not the sort of ones who
go to the gym and train would look at
the body of a man that does go to the
gym and train and respect it
and I think that one of the concerns
that they see there is that they value
something which is now being undermined
by someone that they presume their model
of the world is supposed to be able to
understand hang on a second I thought I
understood what it was that women wanted
I kind of want this thing I don't want
it sexually but I want it in a way of I
I think it's something that's admirable
and you know the secondary sex
characteristics that suggest that men
actually get bigger and go to the gym
more for formidability than for
attraction that that plays into this
pretty perfectly
another element I think is if you roll
the clock forward one more step from
there it might be a little bit of
internalized homophobia from men that
they look at another guy who is in good
condition and they say I bet that guy
slays puss I bet that all of the women
want him I value his body I like that
body in a a way that makes me think why
am I looking at this guy's body summer
oh well it's because I want to model it
for myself and you know it's a it's a
it's me doing it for women but then to
be told hang on a second all of this
that you're doing from a woman doesn't
make any sense at all we're not I'm not
concerned about that
might make you think oh holy [ __ ] this
might mean I'm gay uh uh and then
there's a level do you understand what I
mean
I do that one seems the other ones I I
kid this makes sense this one's a little
too I'm rolling the dice I'm rolling the
dice here yeah okay but what I I like it
I think it's uh it's I like that there's
sort of the creativity of it it's yeah
there's like a Freudian elephant to it I
think it's you know it's interesting
maybe I don't know but he's the final
thing so I heard this story I told my
friend about this idea yesterday uh and
he told me a story about one of his
ex-girlfriends that mentioned she was
happier with him the fatter that he got
and she was more unhappy with him as he
got leaner and I think that a big part
of this is
the level of comfort that is associated
with having a partner that you know is
not going to go anywhere else I learned
this uh from Sarah Hill she taught me
that
uh men who have gut fat are perceived to
be better fathers
and the reason that men who have good
fat this is compared with a guy that's
in good shape and you think hang on a
second how is the guy that isn't able to
protect his family because he's less
physically formidable going to be
perceived as a better father and the
reason is that the guy who has more good
fat is seen to be less potentially
attractive to other mates which means
that if he is given one calorie there is
less likelihood of him spending that
calorie on trying to acquire a new mate
because more doors have been closed to
him than the guy that is in good shape
and may potentially have more doors open
to him basically this guy's physique has
shut off a number of different Avenues
down which he could invest his resources
therefore the guy that doesn't have as
many Avenues open must be the better
father so basically there is like a when
it comes back to the woman that was in a
relationship who was happier when her
partner got fatter I think that
being less uncertain about your partner
straying contributes massively to a
woman who might have anxious attachment
or maybe there's a disparity mate value
there that she is going to feel a lot
more comfortable with that but the wild
thing when you think about this is that
Comfort contributes quite a lot to
woman's arousal right a woman's arousal
is predicated at least in part on
feeling comfortable
now yeah there's like ways that you can
game this in the bedroom but for the
most part it is it appears that women
have a high degree of comfort that they
need to reach the men do so there has to
be on a spectrum from this guy is peeled
out of his mind with the best physique
on the planet and looks like a superhero
and everyone wants to have sex with him
two this guy is super super fat and
completely disgusting there is a
spectrum between that upon which
different women with their different uh
levels of comfort both for a
relationship and for attraction are
going to feel more or less comfortable
and there is a situation in which
someone who was less in good shape would
be more arousing and more attractive to
a woman because her degree of comfort
would be increased so that's my thesis
around dad bod's homophobia and comfort
in relationships for you good that was
no I I think well okay so well the the
first thing you said about uh you know
how how men and women react differently
to the whole dad bod phenomenon and and
Men sort of get angry about it you know
reminds me you've probably seen this
meme right of like you know the guy is
thinking like how I think it'll be when
I get in really good shape and it's like
you know a bunch of girls in bikinis and
how it actually is and it's like all
these boys say yeah man you look Jack
this is awesome and uh you know I I
think like there is I think there is
something there's some some truth to
that right I mean that's like you know
even if you get really muscular I mean
unless you're your celebrity or
something like that yeah the the dream
is not necessarily the reality there
um I think that like a whole the whole
phenomenon around dad bods is maybe a
little bit overblown like I know it's
sort of you know it's it's this trend
online and people pay attention to it
and talk about it and probably in part
because it's it's like kind of
controversial it's it gets people
talking but if you actually look at the
the research John you know well what do
women actually find attractive and you
know you show them a series of bodies
and like you know the the fatherhood one
notwithstanding like that makes sense to
me but in terms of just like you know
which one of these guys do you find the
most attractive just up front like how
sexually attractive do you find this
kind of man and generally speaking it's
guys who are in pretty good shape uh you
know very uh unfit guys like really
skinny and really fat guys are are
um always at the bottom of the list in
terms of who women find sexually
attractive
um but there are there are some
interesting things I think going on with
with mate retention versus sort of uh uh
obtaining a maid versus versus you know
retaining a mate and for women right
that makes sense that especially for
older women or women who are looking to
settle down they don't want a guy who's
sort of teed up you know and and full of
testosterone and energy and looks really
good because you know in all likelihood
he probably has other uh other interests
besides just the one woman and so they
know that if a man is you know spending
maybe more time at home or do you know
spending more time on other things
besides his physical appearance he has
different priorities
um
but I wonder if like if there was any
way to control for that if they would
still you know if like they could just
like I don't know this is like like take
a really good looking guy he's not
allowed to leave your house right like
he's not allowed to go anywhere he's not
allowed to post thirst traps on on
Instagram he's yours he's gonna raise
your kids now do you like him and I
think a lot of women would be like okay
you know in that case he'd all take him
over the dad vodka I don't know this you
know I still think like there's there's
something innately attractive just on a
sort of a visceral level uh guys who
who's in really good shape but of course
like in the real world in reality
um women's priorities change they also
change based on short-term versus
long-term meeting which you know I I
know you're familiar with too is you
know for a one-night stand a really good
looking guy is you know those are the
kinds of guys that win find appealing
versus someone for a more long-term
relationship you know women do play some
importance on how a guy looks but they
start to place more importance on other
things like kindness and personality and
sense of humor and income and all these
other sort of extraneous things too so
um yeah like the the I mean the research
on the body attractiveness thing is like
you know muscularity is like by far the
strongest predictor of like how sexually
successful a man is and you know there's
an interesting disparity here
based on sort of like what what actually
leads to sexual success among men is it
actually how sexy women find you or is
it sort of how much sort of admiration
and Prestige and esteem you obtain from
men and I think this may also be what's
going on with the whole dad bod
phenomenon too is like men even if you
can't verbalize it right like even if
you don't explicitly know I mean this is
one of the sort of uh the the the key
tenets of evolutionary psychology is
like you don't have to know the reasons
behind your behavior in order for them
to be effective
um or even to know that like that's what
they're doing right
um you know there's this there's this
great uh example that Dan Dennett gives
the philosopher in one of his books
where you know a single-celled organism
swims towards nutrients without out
having any understanding of what it's
doing or why and yet it still does the
thing that it needs to do to survive and
and to replicate
um and so so humans are the same right
like we do things we don't know why we
have these feelings we have these
desires and emotions and I think guys
may know at a sort of implicit intuitive
level that you know yes it's important
what women think but it's at least as
important what men think too and so when
men say you know this is the this is the
body that you want this is the body
that's desirable and so on they're
thinking like that's probably I should
probably Place some importance on that
too in terms of like getting Jack
getting swallow those things and this is
borne out by some interesting research
for example
um there was there was one study uh this
is like this is one of my like my
favorite studies like this is a study
that actually got me interested in like
mating psychologists kind of thing which
is that they they showed
um a series of uh women uh videos of men
and these are just like very brief video
clips and then at the end they ask these
women
uh how sexually attractive is this man
you know scale from one to seven you
know not at all attractive to to you
know very sexually attractive and then
they showed a group of men the same
videos of these same guys and asked them
a different question and the question
was You Know How likely is it that this
man would win a physical fight with
another man and it was you know same
kind of scale like very unlikely to very
likely and then the researchers uh uh
attract those men in those videos uh and
had them return 18 months later and ask
them a bunch of questions including you
know basically how many sexual partners
have you had over the last 18 months and
the correlation between how sexually
attractive the women found these men and
how many partners they had was Zero
there was no correlation at all between
how hot they were to women and how many
uh Partners they had later but there was
a strong and significant correlation
between how intimidating or formidable
men rated them and how many sexual
partners they recounted over the last 18
months and so essentially how tough a
guy looks to men is a stronger predictor
of his sexual success than how
attractive he looks to women and you
know I think you can kind of like At
first I found this study hard to believe
this was this was replicated in a
different study by the way so this this
does seem to be a real phenomenon and I
know when I think about you know like
even in my own personal life guys I know
and stuff like they kind of like really
good looking like kind of pretty boyish
kind of guys like they do they do you
know they don't do badly with women but
when I think about the guys who are like
like athletes or guys who are just like
really like obviously physically fit
they do like much better you know if you
were to compare the two and so I so at
first I was a little skeptical but when
I really started thinking about it I
think it makes sense
um and so so there have been other
studies like this too like hand grip
strength correlates with number of
sexual partners over the course of a
lifetime and over the course of the past
year
um you know there's there's other
research indicating that if you ask
women about their most recent short-term
sexual partner they say that like you
know that he was more muscular than most
most of their other sexual partners so
in the researchers in that paper you
know they basically suggested that if a
man is very physically fit and and
muscular he doesn't necessarily have to
demonstrate uh other kinds of qualities
that men typically find attractive
because just sort of being physically
fit is is enough for a short-term fling
um and in those cases maybe women don't
care quite as much about how kind he is
or what a sense of humor is and all
those kinds of things
um so so yeah I think this this sort of
Distinction here between formidability
force versus sexual attractiveness
really gets at sort of what what men are
responding to and they understand that
like maybe women find the dad bod
attractive but guys aren't going to be
impressed by that and and that's
actually what's more important right
physically muscular guy walks around
like you know he's going to be the one
that's intimidating and in the end like
that's going to be the person who
probably attracts more uh sexual
partners uh versus uh you know the sort
of dad bod kind of guy
um and like more more generally I think
this ties into you the evolution of
secondary sex characteristics among men
and and why they evolved right I mean so
David putz he's an evolutionary I think
he's an evolutionary Anthropologist and
he's basically outlined you know like
why do we have these these secondary sex
traits as men uh you know like because
it's actually like it's calorically
energetically costly to have large
muscles like to grow you know extra hair
out of your face to in your voice
changes and modulates too and that that
also takes like extra energy to create
that
um you know thicker brows uh our our
skulls are thicker thicker bones like
all of these things like what's the
point of all of this and he's
hypothesized that this is actually
um you know all of our secondary sex
characteristics or many of them anyway
are are actually uh with a Steve Stewart
really says they're they're deers
antlers rather than peacock's Tails
right so the peacock's tail is a direct
advertisement to women of like look how
beautiful and pretty I am and come made
with me whereas the deer's antlers like
female deers don't care about how big a
male deer ant you know deers those
antlers are actually to be used in
competition with with other uh males and
once they Prevail then they're the ones
who actually get uh more mating
opportunities and so when David putz
analyzed you know a whole series of of
uh conducted a whole series of studies
basically asking men you know how how
intimidating do you find uh deep voices
versus not so deep voices uh muscular
men versus not so muscular men you know
guys with beards versus without beards
the beard one is interesting too like if
you women will debate endlessly about
whether they find beards attractive or
cute or not but there's clear and
straightforward evidence that men find
men with B beards more physically
intimidating than men without beards and
so all of these things more than likely
evolved not necessarily to impress women
but actually to sort of impress men and
this is also why sort of puberty is
delayed uh why you know they're all of
these sort of peculiarities around you
know the the way that the male body
changes versus
why puberty is delayed
uh basically because it sort of it takes
longer it takes longer to to uh to to
develop these sex characteristics uh for
voice change for muscularity uh and even
things for for height right like if you
take like two 10 year olds or rather
like on average 10 year old girls are
taller than 10 year old boys and this
this changes throughout puberty but
there's just this sort of delay this
delayed process uh among boys because
their body undergoes such a such a
massive and and Rapid change and girls
do too but it's just uh it's it's
interesting like girls it just seems uh
it seems like it's uh it's it's less
awkward less overt there's something
else about it like like when a boy's
voice changes and they're just sort of
more ungainly the way that they move and
everything because their body's just you
know it's just a it's a you get this
massive dose of of uh this hardcore drug
right testosterone and androgens and all
these other things so it's really
interesting I think this this idea of um
like masculinity these sort of uh
masculine features and traits uh
evolving as a sort of competitive uh uh
uh secondary sex characteristics rather
than to appeal to others and you know
sometimes I wonder like can these things
like can are there traits that humans
might evolve that could could sort of
push us too far and actually become
detrimental so there's
research on like the Irish uh uh the
Irish elk went extinct because their
antlers grew too large and they could no
longer hold their heads up and
eventually die right because like there
was this sort of runaway uh selection
process and this pressure of like the
biggest antlers were usually the ones to
Prevail in contests but eventually they
got so big that they could no longer uh
mate and they couldn't reproduce
themselves anymore so maybe you guys
would just like muscles will get too big
and you know eventually we can't even
take care of ourselves that fisherian
runaway stuff is so funny what does it
mean to say that
masculine traits amongst men seem and
secondary sex characteristics seem to be
more about formidability than attraction
they are antlers rather than peacock's
Tales because it seems like men judging
other men's formidability is more
accurate at uh estimating the number of
sexual partners that a man has so how
successful he is with women than his
attractiveness is
how
given the fact that women say they're
not attracted to it and yet the men that
have these things are the ones that are
the most successful does that not just
mean that women don't know what they're
attracted to
hmm revealed versus stated preferences
yeah yeah that's that's a good point
and I mean I mean I mean I'm inclined to
say that like they I think they they
would acknowledge that those things are
like more attractive than than the
average or maybe not having those things
but they would State you know this other
kind of preference of like yeah I want a
guy who's muscular but not too muscular
or something like that
um
but yeah there is this I mean for for
human behavior in general right there's
often this mismatch between what people
say and what people do and yeah stated
versus reveal preference and I think
there is uh there's something like that
going on here too where
like for for men what what is like the
you know more so than for women a strong
predictor of your
sexual success your romantic success is
your status right and status is this
sort of amorphous bun like you can't
like you know you can't look at status
under a microscope or something right
it's something that that exists in the
minds of other people and people have to
agree that you have it right like you
don't get to decide if you have it other
people do and in this instance
um
throughout evolutionary history it seems
that men have been the ones to confer
status on other men more so than women
and I know that Jordan Peterson's made
this point too about like how you know
there are sort of these dominance or
competence hierarchies and women sort of
use those you know they sort of use this
as a sort of cognitively outsourced this
burdensome task of picking a a an
attractive partner
the hierarchy exactly and they don't
like oftentimes women don't even know or
care what the contest is right I make
this point in in that article uh about
how like women a lot of women don't even
uh like they don't like sports or they
don't watch sports but they still find
athletes attractive right they're like I
don't know what you're doing out in that
field but I love it [ __ ] good how
good would it be to create some sort of
competition between men where the
outcome was completely arbitrary let's
say that it was
um correctly picking the tosses of a
coin
right and you have this huge pool of man
100 men over time and it's like a round
robin type scenario and then it's
knockout stages all the way to the top
and then get the women to rate the
attractiveness of the men over time and
maybe run the cut run that a bunch of
different times and run different women
through and see if the guys that won a
competition which was completely based
in luck are the ones that are given more
attractiveness and if you can have
someone you could have to control it
somehow where you had attractiveness
before and attractiveness after how much
does winning a completely arbitrary game
improve your attractiveness to women
it's a it's a good question I think that
so if you were to carry out that that
experiment you would need to have you
need to introduce an additional uh
element which would be uh other men uh
respecting the winner I think that's a
key component here it's like it's not
just winning the contest it's winning a
contest That Matters to to men in
particular right like if if you win the
the coin tossing contest or whatever and
you have a bunch of other guys being
like Oh that was incredible bad that was
awesome you need to you need to observe
them being competitive
pedestalizing the person that won yeah
yeah I think that is the uh that that
would actually be be the key here for
for women's sort of uh what like their
the variability of their attractiveness
ratings would shift somewhat based on
that
um and I think like basically like uh
there there's just like interesting
papers on this about like how you know
so so the sports competition is one
where maybe women aren't particularly
interested in sports but yet they fight
athletes attractive uh historically
um you know lot of women even educated
women were were illiterate and yet they
still found uh uh well-known authors to
be attractive uh you know like they they
find painters and artists attractive you
know even if they may not necessarily
understand what's going on with the art
but they see that the the respect and
Prestige that the artist accrues from
the art community or from the sort of uh
the the class of people that they're
around those kinds of things and so I
mean you can see this with I mean to me
one of the more amusing examples of this
is like guys who play video games on
YouTube get groupies you know like
you're just like this guy like playing
games and like uploading a live stream
and commenting on it and they have a
million subscribers or whatever and uh
and I've seen like news coverage and
media articles about like yeah he's a 19
year old kid who plays video games all
day and he's getting love letters and
you know girls messaging them on
Instagram and all this stuff and it's
like if he was just a dude sitting at
home playing video games he wouldn't get
a single love letter right but the fact
that he has a million other nerds out
there like saying like oh I love you man
you're you know you're pre-selected this
is the king of our group well yeah it's
so funny because King of The Gamers yeah
the same accusation that's thrown at men
as them retreating from society and not
being a viable mate for women
video games in the basement spending too
much time on screens if you just tune
that up to high performance and
everybody else says yeah I know that
he's doing the thing that people say is
the antithesis of being attractive to
women but he's the best at it you go oh
yeah yeah well now he's super attractive
yeah yeah yeah there's uh I think like
those like there's something about
um like winning the contest but then
also accruing respect and esteem and
Prestige of other people right I mean
there's if you look at the research on
like uh uh the happiness uh psychology
research
um you know sociometric status is a
stronger predictor of happiness than
socioeconomic status and sociometric
status is respect and admiration from
your peers that is the thing that is
actually a stronger predictive happiness
than how much money you have or your you
know sort of Occupational status or
something like that and uh and
oftentimes I mean the reason why people
work so hard to obtain so much money is
to actually uh obtain the sort of
affections of other people right like
that's sort of ultimately what uh people
are are are striving for both both men
and and women as well uh and so so that
that aspect of of
um mating psychology about how like yes
it matters how you're viewed by the
opposite sex but to me the interesting
part of sort of I guess the male mating
psychology aspect or what females sort
of ultimately choose news is like it
matters at least as much what other guys
think of you you know that sort of is a
more strong predictor than what the
women think of you yes and downstream
from what the men think of you is what
the women are going to do with you
even if yeah even if it isn't what they
think of you do you think that this
pre-selection for mates Works in Reverse
do you think that men are more
attractive more attracted to women that
other women think are
impressive or high status or whatever
hmm I I think that it would it would
probably the answer is probably yes but
the effect would be much smaller than
the effect of of being you know uh High
status or prestigious or something in
terms of like how you appear how a man
would appear to a woman you know there
was a there was a fascinating study
indicating that women are what was it
was like women are a thousand times more
sensitive to a man's uh income or
socioeconomic status than men are to
women and so in a positive direction
right basically the more you know high
socioeconomically you're doing in life
the more attractive you are to women and
so you know that that indicates that
like yes there's a positive effect for
men but it's one one thousandth the size
of the effect so there's something there
but it's not a lot there was a you know
there was there was there was some
research on uh on Tinder you know
indicating that if you're a man with a
master's degree you get twice as many
matches as a man with a bachelor's
degree and a woman with a master's
degree gets I think it's eight or ten
percent more matches than a woman so
there's like these smaller effects like
yeah you'll get a little more your
status can help but not to the not to
the same extent I mean it's it's
interesting even with uh with like your
friends and your peer groups you know
like what what men choose as far as like
and this may sort of tie into the
warrior hypothesis to the male warrior
hypothesis is that like men if you ask
men what kind of friends they like you
know what what what uh characteristics
would you desire in a male friend
um men are much more likely than women
young men are much more likely than
young women to say they want a friend
who's a creative intelligent ambitious
socially connected all of the sort of
qualities that are proxies for status
right and I think the reason for this is
that because because status lose so
large in male romantic prospects and you
know basically some of that status can
actually rub off right where like the
trickle down you are uh yeah like what
is that like trickle down to like the
Entourage trickled out effect or
something where like if you're just
friends or like a like a a hanger hanger
on of like some rock star you're gonna
get probably more attention than if
you're just a random dude right whereas
for women it doesn't quite work in the
same way where like status you know it's
it probably being friends with like a
female rock star celebrity you do get
some benefits but in terms of like being
friends with them and attracting uh uh
Mormon or uh higher uh higher quality
mate or something like that the effect
is probably much weaker yeah absolutely
so it's just yeah it's just different
right think about the sort of changes in
lifestyle that you would have yeah you
can fly around the world with your
bestie but it doesn't necessarily mean
that you're going to be surrounded by
good potential mates whereas if you
manage to befriend Dan Bilzerian then
you you you can expect the kind of life
that you're in for So speaking of this
I'm thinking about the reversal again of
this where
women who pre-select men uh Pete's
Davidson that was in a relationship with
Kim Kardashian and now appears to be
slowly running through every hot chick
in Hollywood uh Dan Bilzerian as well
it's just you know the the epitome of
pre-selection other women find this man
attractive therefore other women
Downstream from that woman will think
they've outsourced again their status
seeking uh radar to other women and gone
ah that is a man that's potentially of
high status I mean it's like commonly
held wisdom when it comes to your dating
profile online that at least one of the
photos should have you with other women
in it and the other women should be
quite attractive because it suggests
that you are the kind of man that spends
time around attractive women which is
pre-selection
I wonder whether the reverse would be
negatively correlated for women
if you were to see a woman regularly
around different good-looking guys that
that would be disincentivizing to other
high status males that may be
considering pursuing her
so I've seen research on this this was
before the Tinder era I think these
papers were probably like around 2010.
David Buss might have actually been an
author on one of them where they they
basically did this sort of pre-selection
studies where you know they'll show
women participants you know a guy alone
a guy with a group of guys and a guy
with a group of women and invariably the
guy with the group of women they found
him more attractive
um and they did the study with uh with
men where they showed a woman alone
women with female friends and women with
milk and they showed the the woman
surrounded by males they found her I
think she was the least attractive
so it does sort of you know your
prediction here was was was right
um but I have seen research on dating
apps where the effect it's it's more
complicated where women will at least
you know they'll say
um that if they see a man with uh with
lots of women they rate him as less
attractive or less desirable and the
reasoning there was is that they
basically think that this guy is not
serious right like if this is the kind
of picture you're going to put on your
dating profile of you surrounded by a
bunch of hot chicks it's like you know
this guy is you know he's he's not you
know he's not a serious person he's just
gonna use me something like that
um so you know and that's that's the
sort of the the finding was they find
the most attractive and as far as like
what kind of like the actual success of
such a guy that's a different kind of
story right but I think like probably
the safe bet for that would be
um like having a mixed mixed sex group
right but make sure that like the women
in the mixed sex group are attractive
and it may be closer to you yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly so I think like the
the pre-selection thing is is key here
but yeah the dating apps have kind of
thrown things into disarray because like
now people are just hyper uh
scrutinizing of like why did you put
this picture up what does it mean you
know what kind of person are you all of
those things whereas like you know if
you just if they randomly find a picture
of you like that it's it's kind of a
different story
talk to me about the male monkey dance
this is probably my favorite article
from your sub stack that you've written
this year it was my I've shared it to
way too many friends so break down what
the male monkey dance is for me
yeah so the male monkey dance was uh
written by this guy Rory Miller in a
book called meditations on violence and
in that book so he worked in law
enforcement and he compiled interesting
research and you know shared his
observations and his findings in this
book and basically the male monkey dance
is uh it's a sort of a ritualistic
conflict between two males typically two
males who don't know each other and it's
a sort of a set of steps that that
gradually escalate and so it's like you
know step one it's the sort of hard
stare step two this uh this sort of
verbal uh sort of a verbal conflict of
like what are you looking at or do you
got a problem bro or like what's going
on or like you know what's your problem
that kind of thing and then step three
if it escalates is you know chest on
chest sort of chest bumping and maybe
like the arms extend right I remember
you had Adam Hart on your podcast the
biologist and he suggested that um the
reason why guys extended their arms out
is to increase the perception of body
size and this is also likely the reason
why during weigh-ins for boxing at MMA
you always see these guys sort of expand
their arms and like you know flare out
their traps and their muscles and really
to sort of broaden their shoulders and
everything is to increase the perception
of their size and look more intimidating
and so guys we'll do that too when they
do the chest bump and you know step
through the monkey dance chest bump arms
go out like what are you going to do
what are you going to do about it that
kind of thing and yeah that's step four
if it if it continues to escalate is a
dominant hand roundhouse punch and then
it sort of escalates from there and the
observations that that Miller makes in
his but I mean they're fascinating so so
he he
um outlined this based on uh his
experience uh as as a police officer you
know outside of bars and various values
you know especially when young guys are
drunk like this these kinds of things
are are uh pervasive right and I it
wouldn't surprise me if maybe not every
guy gets to step four where a punch is
actually thrown but it wouldn't surprise
me if more than half of guys have gotten
to step three of that monkey dance
um and so so what's what's interesting
about it is that uh is the sort of the
the commonality of it across different
kinds of people and also who is involved
in the monkey dance like who do we
choose to get into the monkey dance with
it's always
or almost always two young men who are
roughly the same age and roughly similar
in physicality and it almost never
occurs between a man and a woman uh it
doesn't occur between you know a man and
a young child or between uh you know so
a man wouldn't get involved in a monkey
dance with uh someone who's obviously
high on drugs or crazy uh it it
typically only occurs when there's some
question about who would actually
Prevail in this physical contest if
these two guys were gonna do a fight we
actually don't know who would win and
it's funny you know I remember when I
first read this in the book uh a story
came to mind where I was uh you know it
was a story from when I was in college I
was walking through uh uh downtown with
a couple of my my college friends and
suddenly this very short it was young
but he was a short and very disheveled
and very
um just you know a dirty homeless guy
comes up to my friend and grabs his hand
and he's like hey do I need money and my
friend pulls his hand back and he's like
oh don't touch me and this this hopeless
guy like starts reaching like trying to
like get into his pockets and my friend
is like running around and he's like I
could tell he's extremely confused
because on the one hand he could I mean
it was pretty clear that he could take
this guy in a in like a physical fight
but on the other hand this guy was so uh
dirty looking that he just didn't want
to to get physically entangled with him
and so he's like running but at the same
time trying to demonstrate that he was
willing to fight him so he was like
backwards running his hands were up but
he was still like running and then my
other friend gets involved it like tries
to like separate them but then the
homeless guy starts chasing him around
and my friend is so it was like this
comical scene and I'm watching all of
this and uh and I'm just laughing at it
because like you know I didn't want to
get involved because I didn't want him
to touch me so I'm just watching this
and uh and so that story came to mind of
like Okay so
you know that was a case of like a a
monkey dance that was that was thwarted
right like something's going on here
where like they they weren't afraid of
running because it was clear who would
win the fight and so they didn't feel
like they had to stand their ground but
there was also this part of the male
psychology of like I don't want to look
like I'm weak like I'm I'm gonna like
turn my back and like start sprinting
away from him
um and so so so the monkey dance is like
you know two guys who would win we don't
know usually between strangers oh monkey
dances very seldom rise between uh like
friends in in a group in which the sort
of uh the relationships are established
uh guys roughly know where they stand
those kinds of things whereas um in
environments in which people don't know
who would actually Prevail uh you know
oftentimes people will encourage fights
they'll encourage them to see they want
a rough and accurate estimate of what
each person is is made of and whether or
not they can hold their ground you know
when you see two guys fighting you see
how they handle themselves you yourself
get a sense of like could I take this
guy too you know who would I do better
against
um and interestingly some some recent
research
um I want to say from Aaron's cell I
hope I'm getting that right uh about the
The evolutionary psychology of the
concept of a fair fight and this appears
to be uh an evolved psychological
mechanism of like across different
cultures and throughout this you know
different societies uh people have
strong feelings about cheating in a
fight which is actually I mean it's kind
of funny that you'd have that because
it's like two guys trying to beat each
other up and potentially you know
inflict uh physical harm on one another
and disfigure each other and whatever
and still you know it's like certain
things you shouldn't do and if you do do
like you'll be judged in some way and
the idea that they propose in their
research is that the reason is because
people want this this estimate not only
do people want the estimate of the
fighting ability but people themselves
involved in those kind of altercations
want to uh to Signal their capacities
right like if they rapidly escalate and
and suddenly you know kick the other guy
in the balls and gouges eyes out and do
all these things you know pull out a
weapon then they actually don't get to
Signal anything about their strength
their endurance their their speed their
capacity all those things they're really
just signaling like they're a violent
and crazy person which which can be
useful to signal that in some instances
but if you really want to impress people
and potentially impress men such that
they will confer status on you and you
can get women you know pulling out a
switchblade and using dirty tactics
isn't going to to get you that right
it's going to be like slow escalation
monkey dance fair fight uh you know
don't Don't cheat you know don't cheat
and and uh fight in a way that's fair
and that's honorable
um and I think you can see this with uh
with sporting contests of course boxing
MMA have very strict rules about about
what you're allowed to do and what
you're not allowed to do and you can
even see this with like like young young
boys when they're roughhousing and and
playing with each other uh they can sort
of intuitively grasp that like yeah
maybe you can slap someone but you
shouldn't hit them with a closed fist so
these kinds of things are are kind of
like you know built in and they're you
know I think in itself it's an
interesting adaptation and the monkey
dance is a sort of a uh it is a ritual
around which people can can display and
and also to observe uh men's
formidability and willingness to to
Prevail in a fair fight and if you don't
continue to play fair the effectiveness
of that match up at judging who is more
physically formidable goes out of the
window because it's no longer about you
being more physically formidable but
it's about you being prepared to be more
wild or more crazy I wonder whether this
would tie in I'm thinking like
ancestrally with regards to maybe
um contests for leadership and stuff
like that that you would get Prestige
from winning in a fair fight but you
might get dominance from winning in a
rapidly escalating fight that you would
rule through fear if you were the guy
that was completely crazy but you might
rule through respect if you were the guy
that did things in a more fair manner
that's interesting so you might get yeah
so so yeah the idea of prestige where
people freely confer status on you
versus dominance where you sort of
impose costs and instill intimidation
that would make sense to me I mean I
think in that moment it might actually
work right this sort of Rapid escalation
uh you know using dirty tactics in that
moment it's probably yeah people people
would fear you and be intimidated by you
but if the you know it depends on yeah
what your sort of uh short-term
long-term evolutionary goals are too
it's like yeah you may get dominance but
if you don't get the respect and the
sort of admiration of of those guys then
you're taking your weapons and they're
stabbing you on the way down well
there's that and then yeah they they
don't uh like yeah you don't have the
status necessary to be attractive to a
good a good example of this I suppose uh
to try and think about in a situation in
which a fight would happen and a man and
would choose to not play by the rules on
purpose might be if he was outnumbered
by a bunch of men you often see this in
movies right if you've got one
protagonist versus a gang of five and he
takes the first person that comes at him
and curb Stomps him and totally [ __ ]
him up why does he do that why does he
decide to break those rules it's because
rapid escalation is a threat that shows
I am prepared to go beyond the level
that you guys are prepared to go to and
it it's a scare tactic and the reason
that he does that is long-term respect
and Prestige is not something that he's
optimizing for in that fight
yeah right he's optimizing for survival
yes right and so in that case well yeah
yeah I've seen that too I mean in in uh
fights where one person is clearly
bigger than the other uh I've noticed
that people are more lenient as far as
how harshly they'll judge the smaller
combatants oh you're allowed to kick the
bigger guy in the bowls yeah you're
allowed to kick him in the balls or
maybe you're allowed to like bite him or
or something like that right or uh uh
you know if there's a weapon uh that
isn't too dangerous that you're allowed
to use that too and so yeah I mean yeah
on the one hand you are
um like you're optimizing for survival
over uh you know Prestige or status and
yeah you're also
um at the same time though people are
perhaps you know depending on the on the
context they are still willing to confer
prestige on you if you're you know an
especially small person it begins
someone who's much larger than you or if
you're one guy up against five and you
still manage to Prevail you know even if
you bent the rules a little bit it's
still like okay that was still
impressive regardless and therefore you
know the the sort of the the status
penalty isn't isn't quite as severe I
liked the Insight that you gave around
uh not The Minority Report what's that
what's that [ __ ] movie where there's
like five of them the born born Series
yeah yeah Jason Bourne all of the every
single movie
um he gets into a fight with some
bastard in a balaclava who snuck into
the apartment where he's staying and
this guy comes out of nowhere and they
usually start a fight uh so it's kind of
like a an immediately escalated monkey
dance right so there's no like what the
[ __ ] are you doing or whatever they
immediately go to step five but from
that step it further escalates from
there so they'll have a fight and then
usually Jason Bourne will accurately
defend his attacks and like hit him and
he'll fall through a table then when he
falls through the table he'll pull out a
knife and then you go oh he's not
playing by the rules and what always
happens Jason Bourne never pulls out a
knife or if he does it's it's a it's a
knife as he's been thrown across the
kitchen counter and he he picks up a
peeler or something like a potato
appealer like it you know it's always a
weaker [ __ ] version or I think
there's one I've definitely seen one of
them where he uses a pen I've seen
another one where he I think he uses a
book like beat like starts punching this
book into this guy's throat point being
the what you recognize in the imbalance
of Weaponry within that fight is that
there is something more noble more
prestigious uh about Jason Bourne's
conduct than about this other person's
he didn't break the rules of the monkey
dance up until this guy decided to
escalate it and then it's like as a
byproduct of Jason Bourne's pure
lethality as a human the guy ends up
falling out of a window onto a passing
car or something
well yeah yeah yeah well there were
cases where he well yeah he's never the
one to rapidly escalate right like he
has killed people but it always appears
like he's a little bit reluctant to do
it and like you know because that's sort
of the The Honorable hero story
um yeah I remember like the the first
movie right he uses the ballpoint pen
the second movie the guy pulls out like
this Giant Knife and Jason board's just
like reaching like just like behind him
he's not even looking for anything he
just grabs a magazine and rolls it up
yeah he fights him with the magazine
yeah and he's able to hit the guy at the
guy's busy and so it's like yeah there's
uh the the violation right well
immediately I guess there's this kind of
violation because every single time it's
a CIA assassin who usually shows up with
a gun and then you know born like
somehow you know knows that he's coming
and grabs his gun and disarms him and
then it becomes hand-to-hand combat and
uh yeah they're they're like a lot of
movies are like this where it's never
the hero who behaves uh dishonorably or
who who cheats it's always the sort of
the adversary unless and unless again
like you mentioned before unless the
protagonist has you know five or six
guys all on him at once and then he'll
like grab grab a weapon even if the
other guys don't have one or something
like that I think there was a there was
a scene in I think it was Specter the
James Bond movie where uh where he's on
the train and there's this massive guy
like you know two feet taller than him
and they're they're first like boxing
and James was actually doing pretty well
where he's dodging the other guy's
punches but his but his blows aren't
doing anything to the other guy and I
think at that point he like grabs
something and breaks it over the guy's
head and it actually doesn't do anything
either and so I wanted to kind of
escalates from there but in that case it
was like it was totally understandable
that this guy was literally twice Daniel
Craig's height and weight or like you
know they're they're about like okay
yeah yeah did you have you seen him have
you seen House of the Dragon
I haven't seen that one it's the most
recent Game of Thrones that everybody's
talking about
I yeah I haven't seen it oh come on come
on I never got into Game of Thrones
never I couldn't get into it well I'm
the last guy on Earth I'm gonna tell you
I'm gonna tell you about it in any case
there's a scene in that let's hear it
well
one of the uh like
semi bad guys families it's very complex
right the reason I say that this has
been complex is that you see in one
scene someone take dirt and throw it in
the eyes of another child it's a bunch
of children that are all fighting for
small amount of dominance and one of
them takes dirt and throws it in his
eyes because he is inferior in terms of
a fight and then later on the one that's
had the dirt thrown in his eyes ends up
losing an eye is one of the these other
children
um slice his face open and like cut his
eye he loses an entire eye due to this
but what it shows is that you don't
really know who's the goodie and who's
the Baddie and the reason that I bring
it up is because it it's endemic of the
way that Game of Thrones is written that
hang on a second there is no Victor loss
here the the kid that just got his uh
that just lost his eye also 10 minutes
before that acquired the largest and
oldest dragon in all of Westeros so it's
like what's going on who's the good like
he called these children bastards and
then they have been persecuted for a
long time and you go actually who am I
rooting for here and that that is why I
think Game of Thrones is particularly
enthralling because the typical roles of
good guy bad guy uh protagonist enemy
the lines are nowhere near as clear-cut
and that means that everything is open
to interpretation and I may think that
the kid that stabbed the other person's
eye is totally within his rights and the
guy that I live with might say no no
it's completely out of order and it
allows people to take no one is going to
say Jason Bourne wasn't within his own
rights to punch the guy in the throat
with a ballpoint pen or whatever like
that it's that's what the story leads
you to believe but yeah it's uh you need
to get in Game of Thrones is what I'm
saying right there's a there's a great
uh um uh I I think it might have been in
48 Laws or maybe it was one of Robert
Greene's books where he makes this point
about how the same act can be construed
completely differently based on the
reputation of the actor right and so you
know if if a good guy protagonist does
something that's distasteful people may
not like it but at the same time it's
like well he's the protagonist we've
seen him do these other good things and
so we'll we'll let him slide on this one
versus like if a villain does even a
moderate really unpleasant thing you
know we're we tend to be horrified by it
but it sounds interesting like this this
kind of storyline where like actually
you know you don't have enough
information about the sort of uh the
archetypal character roles where you can
have that sort of mental shortcut of
like he's doing this thing but because
he's the good guy it's probably okay or
you know that kind of thing where like
you have that um you know the the
knowledge of of the the character in
advance and so you know maybe yeah maybe
I'll have to maybe I'll have to give the
show another try sometime I think you'd
be able to not have to invest Seven
Seasons into the first Game of Thrones
and just watch the most recent HBO
series I reckon you can get away with
that and that's like a 10 hour
maybe less than a 10 hour investment and
then you know next time that someone
brings it up you you know what I'm on
about
my taste might be too too conventional
you know I remember I watched that first
season of Game of Thrones way back when
it was on the air or maybe a year later
and I remember they killed is actually
the Sean Sean Bean character
and I remember like yeah like oh okay
and then you know I got a little into
the second season like I don't know I
just I just I just couldn't get through
it so so you know maybe uh maybe I need
to you know maybe my tastes have evolved
since then you've become a more
sophisticated human I think since then
all right man let's let's let's wind
this one up what are you working on at
the moment or what cool stuff have you
got coming up
uh yeah I mean I'm Still Still uh
writing essays for my sub stack I have
some interesting pieces in mind I want
to do a series on this book called games
people play it's this classic book on
transactional analysis by this uh this
guy Eric Byrne uh a lot of people are
probably familiar with this book it's
still sometimes you'll see it in like
airports and bookstores and you know
it's essentially this you know basically
what are the most common interactions
that people often have with each other
and what are their underlying or hidden
motives throughout the sort of uh social
interactions and what you know what what
are the payoffs and so I'll do a series
on that I'm still working on my book my
publisher continues to uh you know uh
irritate me and to yeah the nightmare
industry but the book will be out I
think spring 2024 uh so it's a memoir uh
which uh you know I hope you'll have me
back on we can talk about that and uh
more stuff on on luxury beliefs and this
idea I've been developing too so yeah I
think that's that's enough for for now
when should people go if they want to
check out the stuff that you're writing
online
yeah so you can go to my sub stack Rob K
henderson.substack.com and you can
follow me on Twitter at Rob K Henderson
all right man appreciate you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]